philippe larquier secrétaire
départemental sud santé sociaux de
l'essonne bonjour philip clarke et
bonjour merci d'être en direct ce matin
avec nous sur rt france mobilisation
nationale aujourd'hui une mobilisation
de plus toujours les mêmes
revendications quelques années vous
obtenu depuis aujourd'hui que ce soit le
ségur où ils ont leur temps pour les
personnels à un souvent invisible et
oublier un lieu où le secteur social
médico-social
on attend donc les gens chez al aryane
il n'ya pas venir qui ont travaillé à
plein de moyens
voilà plus et essayer de prendre si les
plaques et dites nous en plus sur ces
personnels qui sont en première ligne
souvent pour aider les précaires dans
cette crise sanitaire qui sont ils ce
que l'on voit pas et finalement qui sont
les oubliés du secteur de la santé
tout à fait sans tous les personnels et
éducateur éducateur spécialisé à l'opéra
pointe mais aussi infirmière ou
animateurs qui a qui travaillent dans le
foot qui s'occupait et qui prennent en
charge toutes les personnes les plus
défavorisées avec dans les masses les
maisons d'accueil spécialisées ou en
examen dans les centres de soins de
prévention en addictologie dans les
années dans les instituts thérapeutiques
éducatifs et pédagogiques
ce qu'on a fait visiter ou dans les ime
les instituts médico éducatifs qui
prennent en charge souvent les personnes
handicapées les personnes
pis mme mais aussi comme je vis et les
personnes
théologie il ya aussi tous les instituts
départementaux de l'enfance et de la
famille qui ne sont pas concernés qui
sont pourtant un des actionnaires en
partie dans les crises au nouveau parti
de la fonction publique hospitalière
e.on 83,0 dans les hôpitaux mais dans
tous ses établissements en fait on n'a
pas deux il n'y a pas eu de
revalorisation du ségur et ce n'est pas
un ami sur lafourcade qui s'engagent en
tout cas aujourd'hui
wassa au point cela va aller les
négociations qui sembla je vais dire
quelque chose d'acceptable excusez-moi
mobilisation nationale aujourd'hui
quelles sont les revendications
précisément 183 euros net de plus sur
les salaires ça on l'a compris quels
sont les autres revendications
les autres revendications ça reste à peu
près sept jours quoi c'est toujours un
pari
donc c'est un des meilleurs conditions
de travail des embauches hauteur des
besoins on pense que pour le social
unique au social où on en pense qu'il
faut 200 mille embauches
et puis 5,83 euros
ils étaient 400 euros qui a qui est
plutôt le rattrapage des dix dernières
années
de baisse de pouvoir d'achat donc voilà
donc c'est soit on va revendiquer
aujourd'hui donc ce matin je suis dans
l'essonne ans nous serons devant la
masse des prix juste à côté de la mairie
et c'est l'après midi on sera devant la
direction générale de la cohésion
sociale qui est 18 places et de ses
martyrs ville et ses fourneaux 14e
l'essonne est un département
particulièrement concernés il ya
beaucoup de ces travailleurs qui sont en
première ligne pour aider justement les
populations qui en ont besoin
oh oui on n'a pas énormément de de sept
heures on a des princes dès que ça pas
hésité parce qu'elle a beaucoup je n'ai
pas le nombre de personnes qui
travaillent dans tous ses établissements
mais oui on a aussi des copains de sa
part de la masse du pardon de la masse
du ponant je suis reparti délirant qui
sera aussi mobilisés ce matin donc moins
il ya beaucoup de monde qui sera
mobilisée et on est très suivi ce match
va durer plusieurs jours
ces personnels sont sont leur travail
est rendu d'autant plus compliquée avec
la crise sanitaire selon vous bien sûr
avec troisième confinement à l'apprenant
aujourd'hui on est revenu en première
ligne tous ces établissements ne
s'arrêtent pas les soins aux personnes
handicapées l'accueil d'enfants
d'enfants défavorisés ou d'enfants en
difficulté ça ça peut pas fermer
certains parents est obligé de continuer
à bosser et les lys en première ligne il
y aura valu relation ils ont aucune
reconnaissance en fait c'est surtout ça
qui le demandent et hélas ses serveurs
pour moussa sow sidibé soutenons
évidemment et nous encourageons on va on
va sur évidemment cette manifestation
mobilisation nationale donc aujourd'hui
du personnel sanitaire et médico-social
merci philippe larqué d'avoir répondu en
direct ce matin à nos questions sur arte
france